welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Rick and Morty season 6
episode 9 titled Rick and King mortar's
Mort this sees Morty becoming an
Arthurian figure after he's given a
sword that takes him off on a special
Adventure the entry is packed with
Easter eggs hidden details and a lot of
things to break down which will be going
through frame by frame within this recap
this is actually the 60th episode of the
show the final number four are finale on
December 11th as always we're going to
be breaking it all down so if you enjoy
the video please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Rick and Morty
foreign
[Music]
which is a play on another legendary
film from the 90s a kitten King Arthur's
Court dropped in 1995 and it followed a
kid that loved baseball who came face to
face with King Arthur he fell through a
crack in the ground caused by an
earthquake and ended up training as a
night of Camelot in the end it helped
him with his baseball playing because he
was crap he was completely crap at it
now this somewhat inspires the entry
slightly with a night-giving Morty his
sword so he can succeed him as a member
of the Knights of the sun Knights of the
sun I I get it now they call themselves
a knight of the Sun but night night it
is interchangeable might be a reach but
it is possible that this could be a nod
to the EP of the same name by the South
Korean band sf9 now the knights done the
classic Knight's clothing with a sun
symbol on the chest a look similar to
the mithraic in Raised by Wolves one
also has a similar design that the
Knight carried in Indiana Jones the Last
Crusade which as we all know what wasn't
the Last Crusade in words probably the
most apparent similarity these are
potentially based on the Warriors of
sunlight from the game Dark Souls the
Covenant even had a similar symbol and
they acted much in the same way as to
the group in Monty Python's knights from
the Holy Grail Knights have of course
looked like this throughout the
centuries but when we're reaching for
movie and TV references those are the
ones that sprung to mind also I don't
know if this is an intentionally similar
Motif to last week and whereas Jerry
received the orb Modi receives the sword
now the reason they're probably similar
is because Rick doesn't seem to be
interested in getting involved in either
he also shows genuine growth from last
week and is actually at a point of
re-examining the relationship that he
has with his grandson we open with the
pair waiting in line for a weird pop-up
restaurant that only enters their solar
system once every so often the amount of
time here that my wife has had me wait
in a car park for a pizza from a van I
tell you the these kind of became the
Rage of a lockdown when people weren't
allowed to open restaurants but they
could deliver food like this yes I know
they were around before that but that's
just when I remember spending days and
days waiting in car Parks now Rick get
some hot dogs that look a bit like
shrimps and Morty picks up the food that
the knights drop this starts off a quest
and it's a similar framing device to
Westworld when people would pick up
dolores's can and it would start off an
adventure realizing that he's good of
heart they ask him to join their ranks
and bring up that the knight's name is
say Helios and that they also defend
Helios Helios and Apollo both appeared
in Greek mythology being linked to the
sun with a ladder being the god of the
sun Elios on the other hand was seen as
the literal embodiment of it hence why
there were two figures Mori takes his
sword and the Knight stabs himself with
it before they transport across the
Galaxy in a sunblast when we see them
land on the other side of it it appears
like the bifrost from the MCU reminded
me a lot of when Thor came down on
wakanda in Avengers Infinity war and I
also love this joke as well before we
talk about the title sequence you guys
still gonna stand in line you're not
gonna take this food the pop-up pays us
to stand here to drive a business knew
it it's kind of similar to how the
aliens kept coming to see if they could
grab the sword and then that takes us
into the title sequence now from here we
see an almost medieval land where all
the people worshiped the sun we've seen
several religions and people throughout
history that have devoted their entire
lives to worshiping the sun and the
Angus most notably used to hold
ceremonies dedicated to it due to signs
we now have more knowledge on what the
sun is and similar to how we can
dismantle religious beliefs through
close examination Morty breaks apart the
Follies of their religion early on in
the entry according to them they're
Invincible they live forever and can
leave whenever they want they also
apparently don't been in the Sun but
Rick Works around this through signs
they'll be uninvincible as Mori was able
to kill sir Helios and overall their
religion can be easily explained away
lots of metaphors for belief systems in
general and how people align their
entire identity with things and make
sacrifices for stuff that might be based
on lies getting super deep so uh yeah
let's quickly change the course and This
Ginger Knight yeah it might be he might
be based on Gimli from Lord of the Rings
might not but just something I thought
it looked very similar to now after
being told the terms and meeting the
king Mori is taken to the Power Pit this
is where the truth is revealed and that
all the knights have to cut off their
eggs and throw them into the sun in
medieval times there were a number of
knights that had to swear celibacy so
they would stay low to the order instead
of running off with women this is
something George Lucas actually used to
inspire the Jedi and removing that means
they'll be unable to love so they won't
be tempted by women now Rick tries to
take Morty out of there but he's only
allowed to live if he best the king in
combat Rick then gives Morty a sword
that uses AI to learn its opponent's
attacks it's seen blade and loved it and
this is also similar to Iron Man's armor
in Civil War in their final fight that
analyzed Cap's fighting pattern and then
came up with a way to break it so that
Tony could get the upper hand it's
basically cheating and there's been
several accusations recently in the
Chess World that certain Champions have
been using AI secretly in order to win
games Anne's nyman recently came under a
lot of scrutiny after being accused of
cheating by using Ai and I kind of seen
a lot of similarities here now the king
commits sepaku upon losing which is what
ancient Japanese Samurai used to carry
out when they thought they had no honor
Chris and Cole also ended up in House of
the Dragon after the Knight lost is on
air similar to what we see here now
speaking of Game of Thrones one of the
knights that reads from the real books
also looks similar to Sam from that show
the knights are very much like those
that took the black and promised not
ever to feel a touch of a woman Modi
says that he will return on Sunday okay
and if he doesn't just wait until the
next Sunday now Upon returning home the
sword goes off and Rick says
hell yeah see that that's from when he's
fighting Deacon Frost Deacon Frost was
developed from the first blade movie
showing that it's all connected and
normally in these situations Rick would
make Morty feel like it but he actually
seems to have changed he genuinely wants
to be nice 22 of the time and more he's
gonna say how much of a difference that
makes now across the way we see as the
sun blast destroys a house again similar
to how the bifrost destroys whatever it
lands on by Frost is of course while
carrying Frost and the Sun is the
opposite of that which is why I keep
bringing it up mate I'm not reaching
that there is a connection there and
they have promised to follow their King
until the sun sets and will no longer
leave him alone Modi decides to tear the
religion apart and because they believe
that the sun scepter is what the planets
revolve around rather than the sun
itself it's quite easy to do it's nice
to see space Beth with a family too and
she of course promised to visit them
more and more he breaks it down Beyond
just the theory time and they end up
quitting the religion however it turns
out that they were keeping things in
check and now we see the sons of the
Moon are attacking the sun coming
together other people of all planets
including the viscounts of Venus and The
Marquis of Mars the people of Venus all
look like women and I think this was
done to tie into the phrase Women Are
from Venus The Marquis of Mars have
their own style too and shout outs to
our editor Matt for pointing out that
they're wearing similar clothes to the
characters in John Carter of Mars a
blind Oracle and appears and these were
typically used in the olden days to
prophesize the future most recently an
example of this could be found in the
north Min with the CRS who was played by
Bjork you meet the Earl of Earth who
looks identical to Santa and also one
that looks like Poseidon though he was
the god of the sea in Greek mythology he
was also seen as being the god of
Neptune hence his appearancier after
revealing the scepter it then devolves
into all-out battle now at this point we
hear the song Goodbye Blue Sky by Pink
Floyd this song takes place during the
Blitz in World War II and it starts off
with a bird chirping which then catches
the eye of a child who then spots an
airplane in the sky this is actually a
bomber which has come to attack hence
the Goodbye Blue Sky in 1982 a film
version of this song was released and
had a similar theme to it but instead of
a child there was a cat trying to catch
a dove this flew to the sky which is
where it was ripped apart by a black
Eagle that represented a Nazi plane it
descended into the countryside and
destroyed everything there before
turning into a war playing that ravaged
the land we hear this song of the war
and watches the scepter is taken by the
characters of their planet Mercury takes
it from Jupiter and both are of course
Gods along with also being planets
Jupiter is shot through the throat with
an arrow similar to my man Kevin Bacon
in Friday the 13th and while Santa is
crucified we see mercury in Saturn
fighting it out Venus uses this time to
take their shot and I think their
character design is meant to be based on
househar Conan from June to their pale
skin black robes and Technology now this
is saying that history is written by the
Victor and we see throughout this
Montage how every time something's jot
down that it's chronicled by those that
have the upper hand it leads to a war of
escalation with more and more advanced
weapons being created chemical warfare
begins with gas being used similar to
what happened in Goodbye Blue Sky we see
armies charging with Towers full of
soldiers and in another Lord of the
Rings reference these look similar the
ones from Return of the King when the
Orcs stole minus tereth there's also
versions of the Valkyries that appeared
and they're sort of like the new Gods
from DC Comics the entire solar system
is threatened because less Advanced
civilizations are given higher powered
weapons which Rick says is similar to
giving the Amish some nukes Morty just
wants to abandon this universe but Rick
says they should stick it out what he
then realizes that he needs to round up
some knights we find them in a drug
house with marks on their arms and
needles on the ground probably get
demonetized for mentioning what this is
but there was that night in the garage
who asked Mori how to get hold of
certain stuff and this is coming full
circle from that Morty says he will cut
it off for tradition and we have
recently seen in society how people
excuse certain things because it's part
of quote-unquote tradition again the
subtext is there which I appreciate and
Rick promises to give Morty a fake
schlong in order to trick them again
this is talking about sacrifices and how
leaders can promise to do things so that
people stay loyal to them even though
they're not really going through with it
he's presented with some rusty blunt
scissors and told to take a step through
the fake schlong detector absolutely
killed me seeing this especially the
Witchcraft one which had a little witch
hat on it rick then uses telepathy in
one of the best and most awkward scenes
I think we've seen in Rick and Morty
they then flee and jump off the legend
of the sun upon fleeing the knights
recount how this brought peace back to
the solar system as it was the ultimate
sacrifice and no longer cutting off
their Willies because of this and it
shows how the society rules have changed
they discuss how after they jumped in
how bones flow to the surface and how
they even checked with a royal Ladle now
this cools back all the way to season 4
episode 8. in that Rick planet of fake
for avasted at a meet with gangsters and
he and Morty jumped into it after the
deal went awry here they headed out and
had to pop up to kill the gangsters
because they wouldn't leave Morty said
how stupid the idea was and the rest of
the episode was basically an elaborate
ruse to ruin Morty's life so that he had
to jump into a fake fight at the end in
order to hide out this is also the
episode where Rick basically prestiges
Mori and we get her a Clapton song it's
in the way you use it one of my favorite
episodes in the entire show so this
explanation had me absolutely dying now
the chopping off has been abolished
another discovered it's kept secret so
that people don't have to cut off their
member in order to be a member anyway
that takes us into the post credit scene
which has the illegal hot dog
trafficking ring being broken up it's a
hilarious Montage to show the crime
behind the food trucks and the police
officer has a similar code to Colombo
and he frees the hot dogs who returned
to the Sea he was expecting a bird to
swoop down and no one does it's not by
the hot dogs and that ends the episode I
had fun with it I was kind of hoping for
a bit more with it being the penultimate
one before the finale but I know this
wasn't like last year where that was a
two-parter still though was a good time
if not one of my favorites from the
season but this one has had so many
bangers in it that it's difficult to
hold it against them either way I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the episode so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in competition right now
giving away three copies of House of the
Dragon season one on the 15th of
December all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want something else to
watch them make sure you check out
either our breakdown of last week or one
of the other videos that we've got on
screen right now make sure you say luck
to the channel as we're gonna be back
next week for the finale and I hope to
see you there take care peace